computer science is so awesome because
the fact that even in that first class
of the second class right
you're really in the need of it right
[Music]
julie zielinski thank you so much for
being on my show how are you
good thank you it seems just like a few
months ago we were back in the lab
working on our
working in cs107a don't remind me those
are the good old days
that was a great quarter how was it
online this past quarter
well you know it it's uh i think for cs
professors it was maybe
you know we had one of the easier jobs
because we already do a lot of our
delivery right remote right we do a lot
of students watching
via video and time shifted and stuff so
and so much of our
expertise is in building tools and
online sort of
circumstances it turns out so we were
able to adapt right we had an office
hour queue let's say that we ran
off of the web your average latin
professor
i bet did not find it as as easy to
transition to move from their
traditional in classroom
sort of way of doing stuff to this i
like the sciences right where you have
you know all kinds of physical uh sure
so i think we did a pretty good job in
terms of transition our class was twice
as big as we
wow right which i think indicated the
students also kind of voting with their
feet in terms of
you know where where can i make progress
you know and work on my degree in this
time of
turmoil and so i we had a lot of people
showing up in cs i think because it
it felt like a safe place to make some
good progress right
i'm very curious to see what the trends
are going to look like now that
that you that it's transitioning online
and how people
what people's choices are going to make
and you know but but nothing will ever
be able to replace you know the the
incredible mentorship that
that you and pat provided at least me
and my cohort you know
coming into the breadboard and
physically showing us how the wires
i don't think we'll ever be able to
replace that no matter how great you
know
we'll make virtual be but but julie i
want to i want to go back about your
journey you know one of the most
popular computer science professors
within stanford
a renowned teacher you love teaching and
at the same time you love code you know
back at next and then apple experience
with steve jobs and
i want to capture everything in this
talk and it's going to be impossible but
we're going to start
julie who are you taking me through your
journey how do you come to be one of the
one of the top
you know teachers and lecturers at
stanford after an incredible career
it's it's all uh it's a master plan i've
known since day one no
i i
california high school right i think
without you know a lot of exposure to
computers or
the field or any of it right i was a
math undergrad in fact all the way
through and
i kind of picked up a little computer
science late right um thought it was
really neat but
it was it was uh it wasn't yet obvious
to me that where this
how this was going to lead it's just you
know one step after another right you
take one class you kind of like it you
take another one you think it's a fluke
you know i did pretty well that i like
them a lot but
you know i'm sure it gets a lot harder
right it's gonna it's gonna
um but uh you keep kind of making the
progress right um
uh i uh i ended up
um at next next was just kind of getting
started right when i was an undergrad
and um so at that point they were still
in the education only market so
there was a lot of attention at the
university level right and so i worked
with
um an actual next
employee who would come to stanford to
teach this class right um
on how the next was programmed which i
thought was super interesting
and it just totally you know caught my
fancy like the
uh like the object-oriented program at
that point was kind of relatively new
and and when you saw the kind of the way
it enabled certain kinds of problems to
get solved
like that it's so freaking cool okay
julie i want to
i want to talk about that why is it so
freaking cool
when the software is written well yeah
because
i mean like you know when you start to
write code right you realize like oh
they're parts that are kind of tedious
right you know like oh you're writing
the same kind of code again and again
right maybe that that figuring out ways
to capture that idiom
right that commonality and and unify it
and and debug it and and put it in the
library and reuse it again right it's
just such a huge leverage point for
which you can then go on to build and
solve for interesting problems so
yeah writing a link list sure everybody
needs to learn this as part of their
kind of etude of computer science but in
the end what you really want to be doing
is solving these problems and you're
like oh i want to be looking at this
data and teasing out these trends and
figuring out what's doing this or
it's like okay i don't need to solve
these problems anymore about a hash
table hashtag that's super awesome and
it's
wonderful but somebody needs to build a
really awesome sorting machine a really
awesome hash table a really awesome
graphics sub system right
a 3d rendering engine and um and then we
all
get to build on top of that like
starting on the 10th floor of our
you know our 20-story building or the
you know 99 form our skyscraper
um and so the idea of figuring out ways
our tools and our
libraries and our systems can can
promote reuse right and so we talk about
it even in early in the sequence right
we're always talking about the design
i was about to say julie you have you
have an incredible responsibility not
just as a computer science
faculty member within stanford but you
actually teach often
the huge introductory classes as well
like the abstractions in computer
science and this is really an
introduction for a lot of students into
the breadth of the complexity behind
behind you know problem solving for
computer science what is that like to
have the responsibility of having enough
400 students in an auditorium
and julie is one of the first you know
inventors and instructors they meet
i mean i computer science is so awesome
because the fact that
even in that first class and those
second class right you're really in the
need of it right
there isn't this really long
prerequisite chain where you have to
kind of spend a lot of time sort of i
think on the background material before
you can get going and do something
interesting it's like from day one
right in in our cs 106a courses right
we're
solving little problems right it's like
okay maybe it's carol the robot it's
kind of a little bit of a simplified
world but you're thinking logically
right you're thinking about
you know repetition and and if else kind
of logic and how you break things down
into decompositional units and it's like
every step along the way is an
opportunity to learn a little bit more
of good engineering practice right you
know and so i feel like at the end of
of those first two quarters right you
have learned a lot
that's actually very practical and and
can immediately you can turn around and
sort of start writing stuff and building
stuff right and doing stuff
people are going off to work to do
internships at google and facebook after
after taking these two orders it just
it's so accessible right to everyone and
that's so extraordinary right like you
know i
i mean i'm not a chemist or a biologist
or physicist but you know i feel like
there's these really long chains before
you're able to do something with let's
let's say chemistry right that where
you're really kind of putting in their
practice right
um and if the cs it's like such a neat
you know steep ramp from i know nothing
to i can actually
do some kind of pretty neat things in
such a short time that's really an
awesome place to be
so so then what is sort of your your
idea or your vision and also stanford's
in terms of how do you get somebody who
comes in and says i want to learn
computer science within this
incredible institution stanford how can
you best prepare me over the next four
years
to be the greatest you know thinker
problem solver that i can be because
there's a very
clear mindset into this you know logical
sequence that we take and i'm i'm in it
right now and i'm loving it i'm so
impressed
by how well thought out it is talk to me
a little bit about that
you know we it's it's totally a team
effort right like i mean i think we have
a very strong curriculum
design committee right that that you
know has is in place for the
long haul right and and we're constantly
looking at our offerings and there is a
you know i mean one thing that's a
little bit different about stanford
relative to other r1
uh institution is that we do have what
we call ed group the ed affairs group
right when there are like 10 of us right
and that we are
teaching only faculty right and so um
the so the intro sequence cs106 and 109
and uh 107 108 one like that are taught
by this group of lecturers and
uh teaching faculty and that means that
we give a hundred percent of our heart
and soul to making sure that that
the intro sequence right how do you even
know that that's amazing
yeah and so and so and then as you
transition sort of out of
intro and into the upper division right
so you start to hit compilers machine
learning and graphics and stuff like
that and so
you'll encounter the the traditional
research faculties and someone like pat
pat you know there and most of those are
also people who are very interested and
care about teaching a lot but they're
they're also have an extremely rich and
in amazing career as a researcher which
which necessarily means that you know
their attention is going to be split a
little bit more right
um and they have more attention placed
on mentoring grad students right and
whatnot so
so us being there right to make sure
that like for example we do a ton of
teacher
mentoring we do a bunch of ta training
right we have
we bring our undergraduates in to work
with us in the intro sequence right
which kind of gives us a pipeline of
people to step up to be graduate
tas right um julie how do you improve
how do you improve on this process
because you teach a class of 400
students
you've just taught it for 10 weeks and
you're about you know now you have a one
week break and you're about to teach it
again
and as any good computer scientist you
want to improve and learn
for the next iteration so how do you go
about doing that
well every uh everything i work on you
can ask anybody who's
who's gone behind me will tell you that
in the directory for the file where the
files like the code or the write up or
the
uh rubric or any of the material
software there's a file out there whose
name is called for next time right it's
in all capital
and it's always named the same thing but
i put it right there like it's right by
the lecture it's right by the
section it's right by the lab um and it
reminds me of
as we were doing it what was happening
you know what was there something that
students got tripped up on it was there
something the tas told me about it right
was there something i just felt coming
out of the lecture
you know or if i got a chance to review
the lecture itself like oh you know what
that just wasn't that clear or i need a
different example and i
make those myself and i leave them right
there because the only place i'll
remember it if i put it anywhere else
right it's like it's
not going to be where i am so at the
point where i'm preparing that lecture
i'm going to start with you know the
last time i had it i'll be like oh
look what i wrote down right this this
example fell flat or this
you know didn't didn't uh you know needs
to be fixed we need to fix this
explanation or whatever so i i i they're
they're littered throughout everything i
work on
that's amazing it's it has to be there
because you know
you're right it is i mean everything is
so in the moment for teaching right
right right it's a it's a thousand
little to do items right of this week's
lecture this week's
assignment this week's lab that exam
right so
um that uh you need a system to kind of
keep
each of them um and then i'd say bigger
things like if you're thinking really
about restructuring an entire class or
really doing something like that right
it's generally going to be something
that we work on um more as a team right
like
there's a much bigger kind of let's all
get together let's all brainstorm let's
all you know think about whether
we recently switched our 106 day course
which has been in java
right you know 10 10 years right to
python right and that was a you know
huge
effort of a lot of people right to um
survey what other schools are doing
right to look at
uh tools that are out there look at ways
that would change our pedagogy look at
the ways it's gonna affect other parts
of our curriculum
so how long have you been teaching these
teaching these monumental classes within
stanford
uh so i've been here since 1992. wow so
so what what
what what changed since then so you've
seen quite a few
you know you've seen quite a few
students go by
are we different than than others you
know it's
uh in some ways it feels like nothing's
changed because
like the core of it is it's still as
beautiful and as pristine and kind of
heartfelt as it ever was which is i mean
i'm saying one of the things that's
that's really important about stanford
is that our intro class is our intro for
everyone
um that we don't have a majors entry
point and a non-majors entry point and
an advanced student
you know sort of thing like that it's
like oh there is 106 a which is designed
to be
called the big tent right it brings in
everybody we want everyone to give a
chance to it and be taught in the way we
want like to build a foundation for all
computer scientists so having
like some of these requests like physics
for poets or something like that where
it's like
oh you're really not going on so we're
going to give you a different uh
white version and we really don't want
to do that we don't want you to have to
select
before you've had a chance to really try
it and so we want to give you the same
grounding we give everyone
we really try hard to get people to
start in the intro sequence even if they
have the background to sometimes jump
ahead
we often think that we can do such a
good job with kind of setting the right
foundation
for you that we want you to give it a
try that don't be in a hurry
um to to jump ahead because there's
even in the simple exercises where we
can just imbue you with really good
habits that we want you to carry forward
definitely
what did we change i would say we um
we've changed the language we've changed
the tools right
our enrollments have gone crazy large
right
right um but in the essence of it i
still think we're doing the same thing
we've always wanted to do all along
which is
is show you how empowering and awesome
it is to be able to control this
computer
and then give you this really good
grounding in
the fundamental sort of tools and
technique and mindset that
makes you be an excellent individual
that's so cool julie what's missing from
what's missing from cs education any you
know at stanford or anywhere in the
world where where are we at now
and what what big milestones do you hope
to
for us to get to in let's say five years
but i think we need to keep looking at
the
service uh part of the of the equation
that um i think we serve our majors
extraordinarily well right i think we
have a great curriculum with a lot of
flexibility
and the undergraduate the master's
curriculum the phd all of that is really
really good
i think we need to keep working at ways
to give computing power to people who
aren't computer scientists in a way that
makes sense for them and so
so as i said we we have this one
sequence and it's for everyone and
that's great and i do think up to a
point we can definitely keep everybody
together
but at there are places where there's
kind of jumping off points where i think
we need to like for example a lot of
people who want to get
uh data science type skills machine
learning type skills
that aren't going to make computer
science their number one focus
and so maybe they're a biologist or
sociologist right or historian right
and so i think figuring out ways that we
can be sure to coordinate
and support sort of you know giving
those skills to people who want like the
way the writing center for example might
be like everyone needs to learn how to
write persuasively and
attentively and so figure out how we
could be computer science
support as a service learning for all
people right
i'd say another big area for us is to uh
dig more deeply into the ethical
implications of the work we do that i
think we've
had a kind of a a little bit of a you
know like hey
we're technology we're neutral we're
just teaching you how algorithms work
right and how
you know how to evaluate them for
performance or for
um robustness or correctness but
um there's really growing awareness that
there there are
absolutely certain opportunities for us
to be reflecting on the bias in the data
sets we use
and then the problems we're trying to
solve and then the
implications of our work in a broader
social context which i think we need to
figure out how to make that happen
up and down across the curriculum like i
think we've traditionally sort of had
ideas there's
a class that you know or two that's
about ethics or social implications and
i think we just need to weave that
through our discipline all the way
through
to be sure we're making responsible and
ethical choices
incredible incredible julie take me back
now to next and then apple
now you're you're out of you're out of
you know you're out of stanford
yeah you're entering you know this tech
scene you get
to work with steve jobs i mean what is
it what is this like
it's so weird that i get to speak to
somebody you know from the roots of it
this is incredible
yeah it it you know it's like i think
it's like when i look back at it now it
seems more amazing than at the time i
i didn't know any better right it was
basically my first job out of school
right so like i thought it's completely
normal that you have like a superstar
right like i
for the longest time like i had this
kind of dingy car this datsun b210
that was like you know kind of a uh an
old
junker of a car and i used to park a
little bit far away from the building
because i thought my car was kind of
ugly and run down and i was you know
still just paying off my student loans
and so
and i i parked kind of a way around the
corner for the building kind of a little
bit out of shape but i it was
interesting how there was
often a black porsche that would also be
in this same spot i picked it had to be
the kind of first one around the corner
from the building
and it was a black person with no
license plates which at the time i
didn't i didn't know these stories yet
about how steve was kind of apparently
like just
couldn't be bothered to get a license
plate for his car right and so
it depending on who got there first like
either i would have the spot or the
black porsche would have the spot
i didn't realize it was steve's car
until one day right i come out and he's
parked in the next spot over and he's
standing by his car talking to somebody
right and i'm coming out to my car
and he and he scolds me for like parking
in his spot
yeah i'm like i'm like terrified i've
been there i don't know
not that long right like a few months or
something but like i'm like i think i'm
about to get fired over like
you know but he was kind of kidding he
didn't like care it was just it was just
funny that like everybody else
apparently all knew that stone park and
steve spot right
how many people were next when you
joined over there uh
so we were we were probably close to 200
people at that point right
i think we've had maybe four or 500 at
our kind of biggest right when we were
doing both hardware software but then
kind of
um we did cut our hardware business and
scale back to the softwares were
probably like so the time we got
acquired we probably were back down to
200 again so
we were pretty small that whole time i
would say wow
what did you look what what are some of
the most important lessons you learned
from from that time that you
then you took with you as you then
transitioned back to education
yeah um i loved working at next but uh
the strongest memory of course was just
the people right that you know
the people who were hired there and that
kind of their passion for what we were
doing was just really infectious right
and and and then maybe the biggest
lesson i took away from next was
i had to go back to grad school because
i was working on so at that point i had
an undergrad degree in math
my training in cs was pretty thin right
i was learning a lot on the job right
you know i was working in
engineering capacity but i was
definitely a junior person right you
know and i
and there were all these people around
me who just had you know a wealth of
knowledge and experience and practice
that i was super envious of right and i
i can i can remember you know people
would casually talk off
toss off terms or tools or you know oh
well when i was at sun we did this kind
of stuff and
and i just wanted i was hungry for that
same kind of experience that
the same kind of underpinning of what
they knew that that helped them to make
great decisions going forward and so it
was great to work with them and learn
from them but i also knew i needed to
kind of go back to the source myself and
kind of
um strengthen up my own were you did you
realize that at the time you were
working with some of the greatest
pioneers
of yeah it seemed normal to me but that
was because
i i never had a real job before i was in
high school i worked in a player piano
place right you know like
you know the idea that i i i thought it
was super normal
to have this just incredibly high
powered
um really dedicated really talented
group of people incredible
solved problems and and batted ideas
around i
i can still remember the way it felt
like since we're so small like you could
make decisions about things and
it's like you keep looking for some like
do we have to get some approval i
remember going to bertrand celay who was
the
head of the workspace development at the
time there was this decision we needed
to make about how something was going to
happen
and um so i go to him he's
relatively new too right so we have this
conversation about what their options
are
we've got some ideas around that he says
okay i think we should do this and i'm
like well
okay but like that's just you and me
we're like just two foot soldiers here
like don't we need to go get
somebody else right for your mom i don't
know what you like something
you know you think we have to have some
it's like no no we're that's what we do
this is
what we're hard to do is make these
decisions and make this stuff happen
i guess we just get to do that and that
happened again again just lots of cool
things to do
and smart people to work with and so i
had so from it i said i had to go back
to grad school so i'm like i want to be
able to go
um deep on some of this stuff and and
school is gonna be a good place for me
to do that i mean i think there are
other people who learn
in different ways it wasn't wasn't the
only way maybe they kind of catch up to
that level of expertise but for me it
was kind of a
i had been a good student and i think
school will kind of work for my mindset
and my
level of obedience maybe or something
like that you know that is so cool
julie as i go on my journey and a lot of
my friends going on their journey you
know into computer science or at
stanford in general
what is the one piece of advice you
would give you know a young student
as we're about to go and you know absorb
so many classes from so many incredible
instructors what are what are some
things that i can keep in mind
as i go through this journey and
maintain perspective
i
wow uh i would there's so many great
things
about stanford right um and so
so many great experiences right and i
the one thing i would say is just be
be mindful of picking and choosing right
realizing that
that saying yes to something right often
means having to say no to something else
and and
and and kind of thinking about like you
know as you look at things there's gonna
be lots of things that
that sound really awesome and are really
awesome but if they're not right for you
right they're gonna eat away from the
getting on the things that really matter
for you so like some of us
it's easy to get people get get i think
a little bit sidelined in the
oh but i somebody else is doing this and
that sounds really cool or
that's you know this seems kind of
interesting or i want to take all these
classes i want to have a double major i
want to do all this stuff and like it's
like by spreading yourself too thin
right kind of you
missed some of the discernment of saying
what's one of the things i really want
to be sure i get from stanford and i
want to make sure i don't miss out on
and that really
are going to kind of fuel me for the
future
and recognize that as i say yes to those
things i want to say yes
wholeheartedly and enthusiastically and
that's going to give me the
strength to also say no to things that
would otherwise kind of cut into that
um i love it i see i see a lot of
students right who just seem like
they're just really spread very thin
and um and i i feel like that
you know like it's it's they get very
over committed right and then
they're dealing with i think a lot of
stress and a lot of um
you know i think sub-optimal sort of
results for that
i agree i mean i think that one of the
you know one of the things that i came
in and was completely blown away but
was by the number of opportunities and
you know all of us everywhere you turn
somebody's doing something so cool and
coming in it's like in a playground you
just want to you know go on different
rides and get all the different fruits
and and i think that one of the hard
lessons that i had to learn as well as
my friends is understanding that okay
well if we really want to make
enjoy this time and make it make it work
make it work for us
you know we need to we need to also be
able to devote ourselves to the projects
we commit to
and it's not going to do service to
anybody if we just you know go and do 22
units and do five clubs
so i completely out i take this with me
uh
different piece of advice next time
right because that is a great thing to
have already
i'm gonna come back for many more
advices along the way but julie i have
to get
three words that you would use to
describe yourself okay
i'm gonna give you curious all right i
think that
i think that's driven a lot of what got
me everywhere i wanted to be was just
wanting to know
wanting to kind of see it through and
then it comes with a heavy dose of
stubborn
because i think that's that's you know
stubbornness and curiosity i think you
know drive all the debugging in the
world right it turns out right is
i'm going to figure this out and i'm
going to know why and i'm going to get
there
and then i think the what makes me a
teacher i think is the enthusiasm right
i love it the when i first at least i
can say
you know i think almost definitively why
i'm a teacher is anytime i learn
something
right the first thing i'm thinking about
is who am i going to tell that to wow
you know like i read something in a
paper or see it online
or go to a talk and then i'm like who
else wants to hear this really cool
thing that i learned so that is
so cool you see yourself as this conduit
for like information to come in and flow
out
then teaching maybe the career you want
to look at i love it
okay julie thank you very very much this
was inspiring this was
you know i learned so much and and i
can't wait to share this with the world
thank you for taking the time to do this
thank you and thank you for an amazing
quarter of 107e and i can't wait to do
more classes with you it was really it
was like it was really inspiring
really yeah yeah all right i like i wish
that's a whole
topic we can go off for a long time
about is like how phenomenal is to work
at the with the people at stanford right
so pat anderson our co-instructor right
who is
uh touring award winner like i just
never thought i would spend my career in
in the company of such luminaries you
know non-stop right
so for a student it's a very humbling
experience
all of a sudden to be exposed to that
julie thank you very very much have a
great
rest of the day and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you
take care bye bye